it's such an amazing universe and it's
such a great game um it's so beloved by
the fans
i'm not surprised that it's being
rebooted
mila how are you great how are you i'm
great okay so festive i love the tree
and the daisy top
it's like it's a breath of fresh air
there's a lot going on on my screen i
just realized
so uh monster hunter the new film based
off the video game series
and look you are so great at being a
part of these video game adaptations
you're like the secret sauce but
what do you think this the the secret
sauce is to making a video game
adaptation
work um you know i think of course
you gotta appeal to two completely
different audiences
you know number one you wanna satisfy
the hardcore fans of the game because
they're so invested
in something that they've played over
and over and
spent so much time like giving love to
but at the same time
you don't want to kind of you know
isolate people who have never played the
game and
um who you know an audience that would
like to see the movie too but might feel
like oh if i don't play the game like
i'm not going to know what's going on
so i i think it's a it's a fine line um
it's something that you know we
we did with resident evil as well was
like how do you kind of make something
that appeals to to both uh to both the
people who love it and the people who
have no clue what it is
um and you know i think part of that
my husband paul who writes these movies
you know he he
wrote the characters like the lead which
for for me
was somebody that wasn't a part of the
video game and in that way
i could play the audience as well to
like come into the game for the first
time
and see it through kind of fresh eyes
like an audience member would
so you know he gives the people who are
fans like
you know the all the things that they
love from the game but at the same time
for people who don't know the games like
he gives them
uh the lead character who's discovering
it with them
right i mean i guess you know i guess
that's what it is i don't know
to be honest i have no clue well
because there are so many fans of the
game do you have a favorite
like easter egg or tie-in that was put
into the game that fans should be
looking out for when they're watching
the movie oh yeah i mean well first
i you know i think something the fans
are really gonna appreciate is the
barbecue scene
and i mean which is really funny because
it's like this huge
action-packed movie with these monsters
that are bigger than life and these
incredible landscapes and
crazy action sequences but look out for
the barbecue scene because it's
exciting it's like you don't want to
miss the barbecue scene
so uh paul w.s anderson is the movie's
wonderful director but he's also your
your husband in real life what's the
greatest thing about
your your collaboration with him um you
know
paul is has such a huge imagination
and um you know he was the dungeon
master when he was a teenager he was
always the one writing all the scripts
for him and his friends to play dungeons
and dragons for hours so
you know i love that part of him and um
you know for me i've always been such a
big fan of sci-fi and fantasy myself
um you know he allows me to
be able to go into these crazy alternate
universes and he writes me these
incredible characters with
you know the do extraordinary things and
make me feel like a superhero so
you know what's not to love i we have so
much fun together
yeah and i think the sets are gonna
maybe become a family affair at some
point because your daughter
ever is following in your footsteps how
do you feel about that
my goodness i mean listen as a mom on
the one hand i'm terrified because i
know how difficult this industry is
um and on the other hand i'm overjoyed
because i feel like
my child has found their passion and um
has been very focused on it for for
since she was five years old
so it's one of those things like i you
know for me for me being a mom
all i want is for her to be happy and to
and to find something that she loves
and for all my kids you know so uh i
think with the right guidance
and um you know she's she's a set baby
she's grown up on sets with her dad and
i
and you know it seems like uh the apple
doesn't fall far from the tree who
who better to guide her um so she got
cast
as natas like young black widow how did
you react when you found that news
we call her baby widow baby widow that's
amazing
no it's it really is because she's such
a fan of the marvel movies
and um you know ever is just such an
incredible talent
she's she's a real natural and um it was
so
wonderful to watch her on set like you
know just
being so in the moment and everyone was
so impressed i mean literally she had
everybody crying
during one of her scenes she's amazing
um i think people are going to be
really really impressed with her when
they see the movie next year
and she's a part of wendy darling in the
new peter pan and wendy movies so
she's going to well the whole family's
going to vancouver next year to
you know to be her to be her entourage
that's awesome when are we getting mila
in the mc i've become a hanger on
a hangers on when are we getting mila in
the mcu that's what i want to know
oh man listen i i would love it but
you know at the same time you know i
being a mom of three is like such a such
a crazy job just in itself and then i
have
my husband who keeps writing these
scripts for me
it's a wonder i have time for anything
else yeah no that's that's a good set
though
so this is not your first uh capcom
collaboration of course
uh the resident evil franchise is so
beloved
how do you feel about the franchise
being rebooted how are you feeling about
that
listen i read about it online and you
know it's it's such an amazing universe
and it's such a great game
um it's so beloved by the fans uh i'm
not surprised that it's being rebooted
it's it's
something that's was so much fun to film
for for me and i think everyone's gonna
have a great time doing it
so if they call you up for a cameo then
and which characters i mean it's always
like so exciting to know like
who's gonna be in it what's the story
it's i can't wait
yeah so if you could tackle any other
video game franchise which one would you
want to tackle
you could pluck one out um
uh you know since i became a mom i
don't really have time to play video
games that often
um you know i i guess like just from the
look of it i i was always kind of
depressed that they made final fantasy
into just like a into like a
an animation an animated movie like i
would have loved to see
final fantasy as like a live action yes
so you know maybe something like that i
mean i love sci-fi i love fantasy so
that like
goes completely in that in that genre
for me
that i love so much i love that i'm out
of time but hellboy was underrated and
it's so great to talk to you
oh thank you so much you have a great
great holiday
[Applause]
[Music]
you